when rock they were there in between
camp and Brock had his daughter in his
hand and people saw him and went to grab
him take pictures and he's holding his
daughter and they grabbed the hand he's
holding his daughter and he just went
off on this dude he's like the nicest
guy ever
Brock's it's always great I guess this
family's like oh my god Brock Lesnar and
he said yeah I'm with my kids man don't
bother me and some dude it was like
knowledge to get a picture and grabs and
they sold his daughter and just went he
just was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing man grabbed his arm while I was
holding his daughter yeah yeah
grab music what the [ __ ] dude I get my
daughter here man and I'm Brock Lesnar
you want to twist your head off
people want what they want and they
don't care yeah I just don't see him
fighting again I'd be happy if I was
wrong
I think definitely wants to get back in
there again I mean I think he has some
some fights in his mind that he would
like to get back I think you mean I
think Kane 95% of the division - he's a
freak man yeah he is a freak you know
picograms know pika great he's a [ __ ]
freak dude he crams that's my reference
for [ __ ] steroids now a Piko Piko so
hot right oh he's such a freak he is do
you want some skeptical hippo eyes for
your boy Nowitzki how about the test
results for Lesnar showed up then went
away on their website and they're like
oh it's just uh just a random mistake
it's just a glitch that $50,000 took
care of how funny is that I wonder what
happened what do you think happened I
don't know I I do not know there's some
sort of shadiness there I think so
oh come on man if you think you saw this
the end-all be-all you got em on sada
says technical issues caused online
blocked Brock Lesnar drug test number
discrepancy here's my prom Joe here's my
prom with this so let's just assume
Brock I don't know
has he had a needle in his ass maybe
maybe I'm not I don't know you've never
done it 100% I would guess well he
tested positive in Mark Hunt fight
correct and Mark soon for that
so so he is not suing him mark soon the
UFC stealing he's still a legal action
what
yeah anytime you see he's his contracts
up with UFC so I should probably get
even gnarlier now so good luck to market
but so Brock Lesnar
we know steroid user his tests what it
just doesn't show up man that's random
but that's coincidence right John Jones
greatest fighter of all time you saw the
issues picograms that's just a
coincidence it's too much of a
coincidence for me ok but wait a minute
the John Jones you saw the thing they
tested him positive correct like what
are you saying I bow by the way did test
negative after the fight even for the
metabolites so heat for the picograms
afterwards there's no people against
you're saying picograms picograms a unit
of measurement correct what do you test
Utah's ative for there were no polite
for this this destroyed which and after
the fight there was nothing correct
right ok because the numbers that what
they're saying is that what he what his
body has in it is a response to this
terror it's neither detecting like
anavar in his system what they're
detecting hissing it's a metabolite
corrector detecting is the body
responding to the fact that this steroid
had been in his system previously yes
but they they just coincidence yeah it's
not that it's a coin you keep saying it
like it's a joke but because it the
situation to me is it ok why don't you
tell me why it's a joke this is why it's
a joke because have you ever heard of
any and before I say all this
Jones is I think whether he did anything
or not he's still the greatest fire in
the planet he doesn't need this stuff
the reason to me cuz it's a joke is
because the greatest fighter on the
planet to ever enter the Octagon has all
these issues there's too much of a
coincidence to me
ok he has plenty of issues outside of
that when you say all these issues you
mean steroid issue correct right now
first one being that don't mean KF but
the first one being the excuse of the
dick pills ok but but it was like they
actually got the dick pills they tested
them this is all documented is it
because well those data analytic pills
gel they found what they found were the
precursors that can be found in big
pills so if it's clenbuterol and we
talking about so so the the thing that
flagged for those do show up and dick
pills yes they also show up in a lot of
other things right but he got them the
dick pills that he took and they had it
in them correct so that means he so they
look but the image isn't in the amount
that he had in his system what they're
saying is the only way that could exist
is through a tainted supplement the way
they tested him before the way they
tested them after the what the small
window of time where he was positive for
that thing there'd be no performance
enhancing benefit for him to take
something in a micro dose or whatever
and that it's in such a small amount
that it had to be a tainted supplement
they got them the actual supplement that
he took the the dick pill supplement it
had it in it that contained that second
he got punished for that this is not
like a steroid that he took where it
made him a better fighter or made him a
better athlete so to play devil's
advocate here so that that stuff that
comes in those dick pills you can get
from other steroids but it happens to be
in those dick pills you certainly can
yes but but that is one narrative that
you that took clear that you could say
what's in these dick pills I'm not
saying I'm saying can do that that's
true but it's in such a small amount in
his body and it wasn't in his body
before and it wasn't in his body after
which showed that it was only in his
body and extremely small amounts for a
small window of trace amount yeah but a
small window of time so it's not like he
had it it's not even like this stuff
which is a metabolite which is showing a
response to the body you be the body
responding to the steroids then let me
ask this Joe okay why does no other
fighter have any puker picograms that
this pulsating effect really well that's
not true I mean other tests admit Frank
Mir tested positive for something got
two years Tom Lawlor tested but Frank
Mir didn't go through the same steps
that John Jones did he didn't provide
them with I forget what the exact there
was there was something that John did
also that lowered his sentencing and it
was remember he's performing yes
he was cooperating with you sada yeah or
agreeing to cooperate with you sada
yeah that we're just cool with that
listen I don't even know that mean I
don't either but let me ask you this if
I agreed to you sada to be an informant
til the snitch that stitches correct but
unless you're John there no one can beat
you up so you're fine but the thing is
is the only way I can inform you is if
something that of that I'm knowing that
I know of
I can't inform you if just off that's
like you'll a [ __ ] that was what I asked
Nowitzki I was like if he didn't do
anything wrong like and what is he gonna
offer cuz if unless he took something
unless you know what you're doing like
if I'm an informant for the FBI or for
the feds for a cocaine right I know my
cocaine we're not gonna get Joe Blow
that makes my [ __ ] expresso we're
gonna get the guy who knows the ins and
outs of cocaine right that's Jim again
that's all my guy
cool or they have a conversation with
him and he says he can provide them with
information well how guys are getting
away with passing drugs and how would
you know about that unless you're in on
that no I don't either again to me all
of it is a little too much of
coincidence that the best fighter on the
planet has these issues the best fighter
in the planner has also ran away from a
hit and run smashed into a girl and
broke her arm he also drove his car into
a tree he's a reckless person who takes
a lot of chances and he does some at
least in the past has done some things
that are not very wise this could social
under that the court could fall is
correct or stop again it's late that was
out I'm not accusing them of anything
play devil's advocate or a guy who is
that loosey-goosey outside that gun
might have taken some
performance-enhancing things because
that would be the similar traits look
could have except in this situation it
doesn't line up with the facts of what
he took in terms of long term
metabolites short term metabolites and
medium term metabolites the only the
only law only long term metabolites
existed which means that whatever he
took he had to have taken a long time
ago now the problem with this is this
all comes from that guy Gregory rich
Hank offers that I say his name you're
talking about the one test the
what I'm talking about is the study that
shows these metabolites is all from this
one individual this guy Grigory were
chenkov who was the man from that
documentary
Icarus he used to work for the Russian
doping the state-sponsored doping
program he's the one who established
these tests and the way he established
these tests is very highly criticized by
people because well it's not suspect its
but it's criticized by people because he
injected himself and and tested all
these metabolites on himself and this
has not been done on any peer-reviewed
test outside of his research
it hasn't been duplicated the problem is
it's not legal to perform these sort of
tests on people in America you can't
just shoot people up with illegal
steroids in America and find out what it
does to them and so they don't know do
that they should I told them to get Sean
Shelby whack them up with a bunch of
steroids just shots before Sean's down
for he wants to get bigger just do it or
just do it - Vitor Belfort wherever he's
fighting just said oh yeah tell him look
Vitor we got an extra couple hundred
grand for you on the side just do this
and let us do some [ __ ] up with dick
pills see how it goes bro [ __ ]
cocaine tainted creatine for real you
would do it yeah I don't know man I'm I
maintain an open mind I do - I'm not
accusing John or anything but again for
me and this is just me it's too much of
a coincidence for it to raise some red
flags for me go I try to to independent
scientists outside of Nowitzki where I
was sending guys information they were
sending me back or sending them all the
work that they did I send them all the
relevant studies and one of them who was
suspicious initially after reviewing all
the stuff decided it doesn't seem like
it's likely that it could be possible
that he could have actually cheated he
said it's more like he did during that
time more likely that the actual the
tainted supplement excuse is and by the
way the team tainted supplement I'm
using the air-quote supplement was never
provided that supplement was never
provided so unless they did it to you
sodding he sada didn't want to release
it the number one question was was it
cocaine that was
tainted with creatine that was that that
was where people thought it came from
yeah because it's really kinda cording
to Nowitzki when he was working for the
government that would be a really common
thing that creatine was used in cocaine
to cut it because it looks like coke
it cuts with coke it's normal it's not
toxic so they would always mix in cheap
creatine with cocaine to make more coke
make sense yeah it makes sense and he
that's what that's what Nowitzki
believed but that's not what he believed
but he believed that was a possibility
I've heard all sorts of possibilities
yeah it'd be answer to know the actual
truth yeah well you know we're not gonna
know that I think we know as much as
we're gonna know unless John comes out
was John retires and it's like you know
I had I had a doctor and he would stick
it in my fingernails and see him slowly
release you know some high advanced
microdose he would never admit that
though nobody ever admit it unless they
get caught it tarnish your legacy unless
it's like an MLB thing but so many
people were quick to jump on the he's a
cheater bandwagon I'm like man you got
you gotta be careful of God careful with
that yeah be careful that but also you
gotta be careful with that but also you
should be suspicious you should be
suspicious I don't think that if when
you sada Nowitzki go it's all good man
it was the dick pill you go cool man I
don't I don't think you can do that well
they definitely didn't do that he lost a
lot I'm saying that's what the fans do
that's what the phone you know some
people can do that I think it's okay to
go Ghana it's just I don't know man like
it's too much smoke here for me it's
okay to do that what it's not okay to do
is to say he was cheating he's but you
know he's busted he's why do you have
the stuff in his system it's fine to say
why is you have the stuff in the system
well there's that's what I said right
but they showed why he had an insistent
yeah but doesn't II should have it in
your system no you definitely she's not
cool - your sister no no so it's okay to
go why the [ __ ] is in the best fighter
in the world system no what are you
doing dude Thanks